the afflecks come out of their newlywed
bubble for one man and one man only
legendary designer Ralph Lauren welcome
everybody to Entertainment Tonight E.T
was exclusive on the Star Pack carpet
the first since Ben and Jen tied the
knot back in July and our Cassie Delora
was right in the middle of it all
Mrs Affleck you look gorgeous I feel
great I'm excited about the show you
know Ralph did our wedding so you know
we've become quite close and we we
really love his aesthetic vinegar served
up something new married couple Vibes
smirking whispering and matching in all
black oh and jyn nailed the California
Dreaming theme her Western look complete
with cowboy hat reminded us of her Met
Gala Ensemble also by Ralph Lauren
another loved up Duo sliced alone in
Jennifer Flavin the couple who called
off their divorce nearly three weeks ago
held hands before the runway show for
the designer spring collection the
star-studdy crowd helped Break TV news
use First The Voice there's a lot of
shakeups happening what are we gonna do
without our boy Blake Shelton well you
know he's been doing the show for 22
Seasons it'll be 23 uh when he's done
and uh you can't do something forever
we're gonna miss him though now you're
gonna take a break from the next season
my family's growing I have a new album
out I'm gonna do a little bit of touring
amen as for a third season of big little
lies where do those conversations stand
Laura I mean we would all love nothing
more we're like family and you know just
very lucky okay so we can still hold out
hope basically okay let's hold out hope
okay let's keep asking might just come
true
Emily in Paris season three how would
you describe the third season
um more more love triangles more drama
more laughs more fashion more locations
more France I've made my decision it's
been a dream job